we turn next out of Washington where the
National Archives now wants all former
presidents and vice presidents to check
their personal records for anything
marked classified that follows the
course the discovery of classified items
in the homes of President Biden former
president Trump and former vice
president Mike Pence as Robert Costa
reports some officials are now
suggesting the government's overall
system of handling sensitive records is
broken
the past six administrations dating back
to Ronald Reagan were asked by the
National Archives on Thursday to recheck
for classified material people need to
be conscious of the rules regarding
classified information on appropriate
handling them the warning from the FBI
director comes after classified
documents were found at the homes of a
current and former president plus a
former vice president who said this just
two weeks ago our staff reviewed all of
the materials
in our office and in our residence to
ensure that there were no classified
materials that that left the White House
face the nation's Margaret Brennan spoke
to the chair and vice chair of the
Senate intelligence committee who are
pushing intelligence officials for more
information across the board about the
sensitive papers that have been found
the notion that we're going to be left
in limbo and we can't do our job that
just cannot stand if in fact those
documents were very sensitive materials
were sensitive then the intelligence
agencies are tasked with the job of
coming up with ways to mitigate that in
Pence's case part of the explanation
from one source is that Trump
discouraged AIDS from admitting defeat
and preparing to move out so Pence's
aides didn't begin packing until after
the capital attack Trump's former
National Security adviser John Bolton
now a Critic says the process of dealing
with classified records at the end of an
Administration has concerning gaps the
transition out process for presidents
and vice presidents is obviously flawed
later today former vice president Pence
is scheduled to speak in Miami his first
public appearance since the story broke
this week and on Capitol Hill Republican
senator Tom Cotton of Arkansas is now
threatening to hold up Biden
Administration nominees until officials
share more details about what they know
about all these records Gail
and so it continues thank you Bob